We talk a lot on this podcast about the fascinating research conducted by psychological scientists. Today we're going to do something a little different. We're going to explore how that research gets done and how it might be done better. Over the past decade, there has been discussion of what critics have called psychology's reproducibility crisis. The fact that some published research results, including some classic findings in psychology, don't always hold up when other researchers reproduce those experiments. Now psychologists are leading a movement to address that problem by changing the way that research studies get conducted and published. So what exactly is reproducibility and why is it important? If the goal of science is to increase our understanding of the world,
在本期播客中，我们经常讨论心理学科学家所进行的迷人研究。今天我们要换个方式聊点不一样的。我们将探讨这些研究是如何完成的，以及如何才能做得更好。在过去的十年里，人们一直在讨论批评者所称的心理学可重复性危机。这就是一些已发表的研究结果，包括心理学中的一些经典发现，在其他研究人员重复这些实验时并不总是经得起检验。现在，心理学家们正在引领一场运动，通过改变研究的设计和发表方式来解决这个问题。那么，到底什么是可重复性，为什么它如此重要？如果科学的目标是增进我们对世界的理解，
then is the way science is conducted and scrutinized right now helping researchers achieve that goal. And how much can we, as readers and consumers of science information and news, trust published research results? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Brian Nosek, the founder and executive director of the Center for Open Science in Charlottesville, Virginia. The Center for Open Science is a non-profit organization that aims to increase the reproducibility of research by building tools to encourage scientists to share data and conduct their work more transparently. Dr. Nosek is also a professor of
那么目前开展和审查科学研究的方式是否真的在帮助研究人员实现这一目标？作为科学信息和新闻的读者与消费者，我们能在多大程度上信任已发表的研究成果？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是吉姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是布赖恩·诺塞克（Brian Nosek）博士，他是位于弗吉尼亚州夏洛茨维尔的开放科学中心（Center for Open Science）的创始人和执行董事。开放科学中心是一个非营利组织，旨在通过构建工具来鼓励科学家分享数据并更加透明地开展工作，从而提高研究的可重复性。诺塞克博士还是弗吉尼亚大学的
psychology at the University of Virginia. Much of his own lab research has focused on implicit cognition, thoughts and feelings that occur outside of our conscious control. Broadly, he's interested in the gap between values and practices, between what people intend to do and what they actually do. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Nosek. I'm delighted to be here today. Thank you for having me. Let's start with how you became interested in the reproducibility of scientific research. I know there were a series of events around 10 years ago that spurred a heightened scrutiny of psychological research and led to a lot of the work you're doing now. And I'm thinking in particular of cases such as psychologist Deutrick Stappell and Daryl Bem. Can you tell us what happened?
心理学教授。他实验室的大部分研究都集中在内隐认知上，即在我们有意识控制之外发生的思想和情感。广阔地说，他关注的是价值观与实践之间的差距，也就是人们意图做的事情与他们实际做的事情之间的差距。非常感谢您今天加入我们，诺塞克博士。我很高兴今天能来到这里。谢谢你们邀请我。让我们从您是如何对科学研究的可重复性产生兴趣开始聊起。我知道在大约10年前，有一系列事件引发了对心理学研究的更高程度的审视，并促成了您现在正在做的许多工作。我特别想到的一些案例，比如心理学家迪德里克·斯塔佩尔（Diederik Stapel）和达里尔·贝姆（Daryl Bem）。您能告诉我们发生了什么吗？
Yeah, in the early part of the 2010s, there were a number of eliciting events that brought to four some issues that have been known for decades, but never really had an impact on daily practice. one was the emergence of a massive amount of fraud perpetrated by Dieddrich Stoppel that came to light because of whistleblowers of his own collaborators and students that had worked with him starting to be suspicious of the origins of the data that were behind some of the papers. But in the end, more than 50 papers of his were identified and then ultimately retracted from the literature as being illegitimate in some way, largely invented data. And the shocking part of it was that these were many of these papers were high-profile results,
嗯，在2010年代初期，发生了一系列引发关注的事件，这些事件将一些几十年来广为人知但从未真正在日常实践中产生影响的问题推到了台前。其中一个事件是迪德里克·斯塔佩尔实施的大规模欺诈行为浮出水面，这归功于他的合作者和曾与他共事的学生中的举报人，他们开始对一些论文背后的数据来源产生怀疑。但最终，他的50多篇论文被认定存在问题，并最终因在某种程度上不合法而被撤回，这些论文在很大程度上都是伪造的数据。令人震惊的是，其中许多论文都是备受瞩目的研究成果，
results that people knew about it, that people were citing and using to inform their own research. And yet no one over the decades of those papers being written and published, No one had identified any of them as potentially fraudulent, leading to people to say, oh, my gosh, how did we not know this? How did we not recognize and building on that work that actually there was very little basis for at least no actual evidence? Maybe they were true, but perked by chance. The second event was Daryl Bem, a renowned social psychologist, has done wonderful work
人们都知道这些成果，人们一直在引用它们，并用它们来为自己的研究提供参考。然而，在这些论文被撰写和发表的几十年里，竟然没有人将其中任何一篇识别为潜在的欺诈行为，这导致人们不禁感叹：天哪，我们怎么会不知道？我们怎么没有在这些实际上几乎没有什么根据（或者说至少没有任何实际证据）的工作上去进行识别和推进呢？也许它们是真的，但只是碰巧蒙对了。第二个事件是达里尔·贝姆，他是一位著名的社会心理学家，在他的整个职业生涯中做出了出色的工作，
throughout his career, got interested later in his career. career in the potential for ESP and other paranormal types of paraps of psychological types of things as possibly being true, and so he started to study them. And he published a paper in one of APA's flagship journals, the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, showing evidence across multiple experiments of ESP. And this created an outcry, reaction among psychologists because they said how could, you know, a leading journal in our field publish something that is so obviously flawed that can't be true. And then others on the other side saying, well, look at what he reported. It looks like every other paper that we publish in this journal.
但在其职业生涯的后期，他开始对ESP（超感官知觉）以及其他可能为真的超自然心理学现象的潜力产生兴趣，于是他开始研究这些。他在美国心理学协会的旗舰期刊之一——《人格与社会心理学杂志》（Journal of Personality and Social Psychology）上发表了一篇论文，通过多项实验展示了ESP的证据。这在心理学家中引发了强烈的抗议和反应，因为他们说，你怎么能——你知道的——在我们领域的顶尖期刊上发表如此明显存在缺陷、不可能是真的东西呢？而另一方则说，看，他报告的内容跟我们在该期刊上发表的任何其他论文都一样。
It follows the same standards of evidence. In fact, it does so in a really remarkably great way compared to many of the papers that are published in this journal. So what it created was this tension of either we need to now believe that ESP is true because the paper follows all of our rules for what it takes to provide evidence, or we need to question our rules because they allowed something that seems to be a fantastical conclusion to come to light. And then the third event that comes with these two around the same time was a publication of a paper called False Positive Psychology by Laif Nelson, Joe Simmons, and Uri Simonson, where they essentially consolidated this many decades of insight of ways that we might create false positive results, results that aren't actually true through our practices of how we get our data and how we analyze our data. And it's a rhetorically brilliant paper because what it does is it gives the reader,
它遵循了同样的证据标准。事实上，与在该期刊上发表的许多论文相比，它在这方面做得非常出色。因此，这就产生了一种紧张关系：要么我们现在需要相信ESP是真的，因为这篇论文遵循了我们关于提供证据所需的所有规则；要么我们需要质疑我们的规则，因为它们允许一个看起来荒诞不经的结论大白于天下。紧接着，与这两个事件大约在同一时期发生的第三个事件是，莱夫·纳尔逊（Leif Nelson）、乔·西蒙斯（Joe Simmons）和乌里·西蒙森（Uri Simonsohn）发表了一篇名为《假阳性心理学》（False Positive Psychology）的论文，他们基本上总结了数十年来关于如何产生假阳性结果（即通过我们获取数据和分析数据的方式，得出实际上并不真实的结论）的各种方法的深刻见解。这是一篇修辞上极其出色的论文，因为它让读者——
who has some experience with analyzing their own data, a sense of here's something that you might do, which are very common kinds of behaviors. And here's the implications that has for increasing the likelihood that your findings are no longer credible. And just through a sequence of examples, they show that what would a third? ostensibly be something that might be, create 5% false positives, right? Seeing signal where there isn't anything might actually end up being 60% or higher false positive rates. Like, whoa, most of my findings are not actually there because of how I analyze my data.
那些对分析自己的数据有一些经验的读者——产生了一种感觉：这里有些事你可能会做，而这些都是非常常见的行为。并且这会对增加你的发现不再可信的可能性产生影响。仅仅通过一系列的例子，他们表明，原本表面上可能是创造5%假阳性结果（对吧？看到本来不存在的信号）的事情，实际上最终可能会达到60%甚至更高的假阳性率。就像，哇，由于我分析数据的方式，我的大部分发现其实根本不存在。
So each of these created shockwaves in its own way of something is not right here, and we need to do something about it. Shouldn't the peer review process prevent such flawed research from being published? And sometimes if a study's conclusion are too convenient or too good to be true, aren't they accorded a more stringent level of scrutiny? It would be great if that were true. And the challenges with why it isn't true are a couple of fold. One, peer review is hard, right? I am reading what you did in your research and I'm trying to understand it, trying to recognize limitations.
因此，这些事件中的每一个都以其独特的方式产生了冲击波，让人觉得这里有些不对劲，我们必须采取行动。同行评议过程难道不应该阻止这种有缺陷的研究发表吗？有时，如果一项研究的结论过于便利或好得令人难以置信，难道不应该对它们进行更严格的审查吗？如果真是那样就好了。之所以并非如此，原因有以下几个方面。首先，同行评议很难，对吧？我正在阅读你在研究中所做的事情，我试图去理解它，试图识别它的局限性，
of it, trying to say, oh, here's some things that you might trust, might not trust. So just that work itself is hard because you had to write down what you did. I have to interpret what you did, and I have to come to some understanding in the process. But let's say I'm really good at it as a reviewer. It's also really hard because it isn't transparent. All I have to review of what you did is what you wrote down. So taking that example of, of these many different analyses that you might do and just report the ones that make the finding come out but actually increase its false positive rate,
试图说：“哦，这里有些东西你可以信任，有些可能不能信任。”所以单单这项工作本身就很困难，因为你必须写下你所做的事情，而我必须解读你所做的事情，并在这一过程中达成某种理解。但假设我作为一个审稿人非常擅长此道。这也真的很困难，因为它并不透明。我所能审查的关于你所做的事情，仅仅是你写下来的内容。因此，拿这个例子来说，你可能会做许多不同的分析，却只报告那些让研究结果成立的分析，但这实际上增加了假阳性率，
if you don't show me all those other analyses that you did, for me to then say, hang on a second, you analyze this 50 ways, you only showed me the one way, like what happened to the other 49 ways? If I don't see that, there's no way for me to catch it in peer review. Right, I didn't like the way those turned out. Yeah, right, right. In the Diedrich Stoppel case,
如果你不把我所做的所有其他分析都展示给我，让我说：“等一下，你用50种方法分析了这个，却只给我看了一种，那另外49种方法怎么了？”如果我看不到这一点，我在同行评议中就根本无法捕捉到它。没错，我不喜欢那些分析结果呈现出来的样子。是的，没错，没错。在迪德里克·斯塔佩尔的案例中，
well, he knows how to write a paper. And how am I to know that the data aren't there, aren't real, if I can't access the data? So one of the big limitations of the peer review process, besides not in being imperfect, and that's just part of the system, no system like that will be perfect because science is hard, and it takes a while to figure things out. But one of the big barriers for effective peer review and ultimately self-correction is a lack of transparency. If you can't see what I did, how I did, can't see the data that I generated, then there's very little chance that you can effectively evaluate the quality of my work.
嗯，他知道如何撰写论文。如果我无法访问数据，我又怎么知道数据不在那里、不是真实的呢？因此，同行评议过程的一大局限性（除了它本身并不完美之外，这只是系统的一部分，没有任何这样的系统会是完美的，因为科学很难，弄清楚事情需要时间）在于缺乏透明度。如果你看不到我做了什么、我是怎么做的，也看不到我生成的数据，那么你几乎没有可能有效地评估我工作的质量。
So your organization is called the Center for Open Science, and I'm hoping you can explain for our listeners, many of whom are not psychologists. In fact, most of whom are not psychologists, what you mean by that? How does it relate to the reproducibility problem that we're talking about right now? Yeah. So the Center for Open Science is a nonprofit technology and culture change organization that has a mission to increase openness, integrity, and reproducibility of research. And it spun out of my lab in 2013.
所以你们的组织叫做开放科学中心，我希望你能为我们的听众解释一下这个名字的含义——我们的许多听众并不是心理学家，事实上，其中大多数都不是心理学家。这与我们现在讨论的可重复性问题有什么关系？是的。开放科学中心是一个非营利性的技术与文化变革组织，其使命是提高研究的开放性、完整性和可重复性。它于2013年从我的实验室独立出来。
Jeff Spees and I launched the organization. Our goal was to say to recognize that this is a culture challenge. This isn't a matter of just teaching people how to do it. research in a better way, having them read Uri Leif and Joe's paper and say, okay, don't do those things and your research will be fine. That's helpful, right? We need education and training about how to do the best research we can. But really, as a researcher in the field, I have two major constraints that make it so that the work that I do might be less credible than I want it to be. One is the limitations of my own mind.
杰夫·斯皮斯（Jeff Spees）和我共同创立了这个组织。我们的目标是认识到这是一个文化挑战。这不仅仅是教导人们如何以更好的方式开展研究，让他们阅读乌里、莱夫和乔的论文，然后说：“好了，别做那些事，你的研究就会没问题。”这当然是有帮助的，对吧？我们需要关于如何开展最佳研究的教育和培训。但事实上，作为该领域的연구人员，我有两个主要的制约因素，这使得我所做的工作可能不如我希望的那样可信。首先是我自己思维的局限性。
I intend to do good work. I intend to find out things that are true. But I have skin in the game. If I find something super exciting, that advances my career. I'm more likely to get a job. I'm more likely to get tenure at my institution. I'm more likely to get awards. And if I find things that don't work a lot and things that are kind of messy,
我打算做好工作，我打算找出真实的事情。但我在其中有切身利益。如果我发现了一些超级令人兴奋的事情，这会推进我的职业生涯。我更有可能找到工作，更有可能在我的机构获得终身教职，更有可能获得奖项。而如果我发现了很多行不通的事情，或者发现事情一团糟，
well, that's not going to do as much for my career. So I have a conflict of interest with my own results. And so I may bring to bear lots of not reasons, but rationalizations for how it is I can justify reporting this finding rather than that finding. Why it is I would take these two studies that looked really good for my phenomenon and decide that those four studies that didn't find evidence for it were actually just bad studies. So I shouldn't report them at all.
嗯，这对我的职业生涯就没有那么大的帮助了。因此，我对自己的研究结果存在利益冲突。所以，对于如何证明自己报告这个发现而不是那个发现是正当的，我可能会找出许多并非理由的理由来进行合理化解释。为什么我会挑出这两项看起来对我的现象非常有利的研究，却决定那四项没有找到证据的研究其实都是糟糕的研究，因此我根本不应该报告它们。
So the bias that I bring to the table, I may not recognize in how it is I do my work. And so we have that constraint is how do we help ourselves be more credible by being more transparent and confront our own biases, just like we study biases about how we make judgments of other people in everyday life and implicit bias. Same sorts of principles about scientific evidence. The second major constraint is the structure of the system, how it is that I'm rewarded, right? Because I need to get those exciting findings, though that constraint, that part of the structure of the system, what universities do to decide who to hire and who to promote, what journals
因此，我带进研究中的偏见，可能在自己做事的方式中并未意识到。所以我们面临的制约因素是：我们如何通过更加透明来帮助自己变得更可信，并直面我们自己的偏见？正如我们在日常生活中研究关于如何对他人做出判断的偏见以及内隐偏见一样。科学证据也同样适用这些原则。第二个主要制约因素是系统的结构，也就是我如何获得奖励，对吧？因为我需要获得那些令人兴奋的发现——系统的这一结构性部分，即大学如何决定聘用谁和晋升谁，期刊
do to decide which findings to publish, what funders do decide who to give grants to, those create a system that constrains my behavior as much as I want to do things well. In order to be in that system, I have to align to some degree to those reward systems. So what the Center for Open Science exists to do is to confront both of these and try to facilitate a change in the research culture. And it does so by providing technology for researchers to make it easy to be more transparent, to show you what my plans were in advance, to show all of the things that I found,
如何决定发表哪些发现，资助者如何决定将资助给谁——这些创造了一个系统，无论我多么想把事情做好，它都在约束着我的行为。为了在这个系统中生存，我必须在某种程度上顺应那些奖励系统。因此，开放科学中心存在的目的，就是直面这两者，并努力促进研究文化的变革。它通过提供技术来帮助研究人员轻松做到更加透明：提前展示我的计划是什么，展示我发现的所有事情，
not putting anything, hiding anything away, to making my data available to you to reanalyze it. And we work on the structure, working with publishers and funders and institutions, to try to nudge those policies and incentives so that what researchers are rewarded for is doing rigorous, transparent research, rather than producing exciting findings that may not be credible.
不隐瞒任何东西，让我的数据可供你重新分析。我们致力于结构层面的改革，与出版商、资助者和机构合作，试图调整这些政策和激励措施，以便研究人员因开展严谨、透明的研究而获得奖励，而不是因产生可能不可信的激动人心的发现而获得奖励。
Your center encourages several things, open data, open materials, and pre-registration of studies. What are each of those practices and how are they helping with science being more credible and more transparent? So with open data, if you want to be able to analyze my data to see if I found, what I said I found, simple reproduction, you can't do that unless you have access to my data. If you'd like to see whether my findings are robust, if you change an analyst this way, analysis that way, all different reasonable choices you might make and see if the same findings recur, you need access to the data. Or if you want to combine the data I generated with similar kinds of data by many other researchers to see how robust is the phenomenon when you look in Virginia,
你们的中心鼓励几项事情：开放数据、开放材料和研究预注册。这些做法分别是什么？它们如何帮助科学变得更加可信和透明？关于开放数据，如果你想能够分析我的数据，看看我是否发现了、我所说我发现的东西，即简单的重复，除非你能访问我的数据，否则你无法做到这一点。如果你想看看我的发现是否稳健，如果你以这种方式或那种方式改变分析（你可能会做出各种不同的合理选择），并看看是否会出现同样的发现，你需要访问数据。或者，如果你想把我生成的数据与许多其他研究人员的类似数据结合起来，看看当你审视弗吉尼亚州时，
where I am and participants in Iowa and participants in Israel and participants in Russia, then you need to be able to aggregate that data. And you can do some of that metanalytically with just the outcomes, but it's even more powerful to be able to look at the raw data in aggregate. So that open data is part of where we started earlier when you asked about the peer review process, is if we want to be able to self-correct effectively and assess credibility, having access to the original data is very useful. For open materials, you want to see how is it that I generated that data.
也就是我所在的地方，以及爱荷华州的参与者、以色列的参与者和俄罗斯的参与者时，这种现象有多么稳健，那么你需要能够聚合这些数据。你可以仅通过结果进行某种元分析（meta-analytical），但如果能够将原始数据聚合起来看，则会更强大。因此，开放数据正是我们早些时候谈到同行评议过程时的起点：如果我们想要有效地进行自我纠正并评估可信度，访问原始数据是非常有用的。对于开放材料，你想看看我是如何生成这些数据的。
You want to know what was the exact format of the survey or the behavioral intervention that I did or what it is that the people did in the setting when I was trying to elicit their behavior. If you don't have access to all of the actual content of the study, how the study was conducted, it's hard for you to then assess the credibility of the data. It's also hard for you to say, you know what?
你想知道调查的确切格式是什么，或者我所做的行为干预是什么，或者当我试图引发出人们的行为时，他们在那种环境下做了什么。如果你无法访问研究的所有实际内容、研究是如何进行的，你就很难评估数据的可信度。你也很难说：“你知道吗？
I want to know if that replicates in this other context. Sure, he showed it in his lab under these very limited conditions, but really if that's meaningful evidence, it should also occur in a corporate environment or it should occur in everyday life in some way. And so I want to test it over in this population or that population. Not having access to materials makes it harder for you to assess how it is I did it and then to redo it. So sharing that, again, provides better, effective,
我想知道这在其他语境下是否能重复出来。”当然，他在极其有限的条件下在自己的实验室里展示了这一点，但如果这确实是有意义的证据，它也应该发生在企业环境中，或者应该以某种方式发生在日常生活中。因此，我想在这个群体或那个群体中对其进行测试。无法访问材料会使你更难评估我是如何做到这一点的，进而更难将其重做。因此，分享这些材料同样提供了更好、更有效的
self-correction, extension, and building on each other's evidence. The last one, pre-registration, has two important roles. The first, what pre-registration means is when I plan to do a study, I write down some information about what the study is going to be and how I'm going to analyze the data, and I post that in an independent repository, so that in principle, anyone can discover all of the studies that I plan to do. And so the two problems that solves is, first, the publication bias. We talked about earlier where I do 10 studies, and I only show you the three that worked. Well, now, if I've pre-registered all of my studies in advance, you can find the other seven. you can say, oh, wait a second, Brian.
自我纠正、扩展以及在彼此证据基础上的构建。最后一点，预注册，具有两个重要的作用。首先，预注册的意思是，当我计划做一项研究时，我写下关于该研究将是什么以及我将如何分析数据的一些信息，并将其发布在一个独立的存储库中，以便原则上任何人都可以发现我计划做的所有研究。因此，它解决的两个问题是：首先是发表偏差。我们之前讨论过我做了10项研究，却只给你展示了起作用的3项。现在，如果我提前预注册了我所有的研究，你就能找到另外7项，
Is the evidence as credible as you say it is? Like, what happened to these? And I say, oh, no, no, no. Those were bad studies, you know, and you might agree or you might disagree. But at least you can see the evidence. The other reason for pre-registration is that it makes very clear what was planned beforehand and what I discovered after the fact. And both of those modes of research are super important.
你就可以说：“哦，等一下，布赖恩，这些证据真的像你说的那么可信吗？这些研究怎么了？”然后我说：“哦，不，不，不，那些都是糟糕的研究，你知道的。”你可能会同意，也可能会不同意。但至少你能看到这些证据。预注册的另一个原因是，它让人非常清楚地看出什么是事先计划好的，什么是事后发现的。这两种研究模式都超级重要。
We have confirmatory modes of research where it is I have a hypothesis in advance. This theory makes these kinds of predictions. And so I'm going to collect some data to test the viability of my theory. See where it holds up. See where it's weak. And then revise our confidence in the theory as a consequence. That confirmatory part, it's really important to say in advance, how are you going to test it? And so then afterwards, I don't say, oh, actually my prediction is a little bit different.
我们有验证性的研究模式，也就是我事先有一个假设。这个理论做出了这些预测，因此我将收集一些数据来测试我的理论的可行性，看看它在哪里经得起检验，在哪里薄弱，并因此修正我们对该理论的信心。对于验证性部分，事先说明你将如何进行测试是非常重要的。这样在事后，我就不会说：“哦，其实我的预测有点不同，
and I think it only alternatives. So I don't do that sort of reconstruction after the fact. The other part of that is that the evidence itself becomes easier to assess because then once I've seen the data, I am free to go into it and explore and discover new things and find out what's in the data that might shape new ideas, might generate hypotheses for me to test next. And that's where a lot of the new discovery in science occurs, right? It's not from what we're testing from existing hypotheses or theories. It's when the data go totally awry and send us in a whole new direction.
而且我认为只有其他选择。”所以我不会进行那种事后的重构。这的另一个部分是，证据本身变得更容易评估了，因为一旦我看到了数据，我就可以自由地进入其中进行探索和发现新事物，找出数据中可能塑造新想法的内容，并为我接下来要测试的假设生成灵感。这就是科学中许多新发现发生的地方，对吧？它不是来自于我们从现有假设或理论中测试的内容，而是当数据完全偏离轨道，把我们带向全新方向的时候。
Like, wow, I didn't think that was going to happen. And that is super important. But it's also very important to recognize that it's more uncertain. When data go in a different direction than expected, what we would ordinarily want to do is follow up on it, develop some hypotheses and test those hypotheses for why it went in that new direction. So pre-registration helps keep clear when we're in these two different modes of research so that we can respect and value both of them.
就像：“哇，我没想到会这样。”这超级重要。但同样非常重要的是要认识到，这是更加不确定的。当数据朝着与预期不同的方向发展时，我们通常想要做的事情是跟进它、开发一些假设，并测试这些假设，弄清楚为什么它会朝那个新方向发展。因此，预注册有助于保持清晰，让我们知道自己何时处于这两种不同的研究模式中，以便我们能够尊重和珍视这两种模式。
So if I pre-register a study and I say I'm going to conduct these 10 experiments as part of my study, does this commit me to using all of them or maybe I find that six out of the 10 confirm the hypothesis and the other four don't. But I've told everybody that I did it. I mean, can I still submit the paper and leave out those four? How committed am I to including everything? Pre-registration doesn't force you to do anything at all. It just makes it so that it's transparent what it is you did.
所以，如果我预注册了一项研究，并说我将把这10个实验作为我研究的一部分，这是否意味着我必须全部使用它们？或者也许我发现10个里面有6个证实了假设，另外4个没有。但我已经告诉了所有人我做了这些。我的意思是，我还能提交论文并把那4个漏掉吗？我对包含所有内容到底有多大程度的承诺？预注册根本不强迫你做任何事情。它只是让你的所作所为变得透明。
So this happens all the time, right? I plan a number of studies. I pre-register them in our lab, and then a couple of them go sideways, right? Like, even just implementing the study, I had a plan for how we were going to do it, and I can't do it that way. So, like, it is a broken study. But many times it's more like what you described. Like, it just doesn't turn out the way that I thought. And so I can say, well, these are the ones I'm going to report.
所以这种情况一直都在发生，对吧？我计划了一系列研究。我们在实验室里对它们进行了预注册，然后其中有一两项进展不顺，对吧？就像，甚至在实施研究时，我有一个关于我们打算如何做的计划，但我无法按那种方式做。所以，这就成了一项失败的研究。但很多时候，情况更像是你所描述的那样，只是结果没有像我想象的那样呈现。所以我会说：“好吧，这些是我要报告的。”
But the value of pre-registration is in those other ones are also available. They're also accessible for you as a reader or for anybody in the community to say, well, I want to, want to consider that evidence too. And so the goal of pre-registration is not to say, here are these strict rules that you now have to follow. It's here is a way to articulate and make plain what your plans were and compare that to what you did. And I can tell you why I had to make those changes. We planned to do this study with 1,0006-month-olds to measure their attention towards this versus that get into the study. Turns out it's hard to do research with six months old. We thought a thousand that was crazy. We're going to do it with 20, right, or whatever it is. And so at least I can
但预注册的价值在于，那些其他的研究也是可用的。作为读者或社区中的任何人，你也可以访问它们，说：“嗯，我也想考虑一下这些证据。”因此，预注册的目标并不是说：“这里有这些严格的规则，你现在必须遵守。”而是说：“这里有一种方法，可以阐明和说明你的计划是什么，并将其与你的实际做法进行比较。”我可以告诉你为什么我必须做出这些更改。我们计划对1000名6个月大的婴儿进行这项研究，以衡量他们对这个与那个的注意力——结果进入研究后发现，对6个月大的婴儿进行研究很难。我们觉得一千个太疯狂了，我们要对20个进行研究，或者诸如此类。所以至少我可以
then follow up and say, here's what we had to change. This is why we had to change it. And this is what we think implications it has for how confident you should be in our results. And then you as a reader get to say, hmm, I'm glad I can see that. I'm glad I can understand how it is he got from here to there, and I either agree with his explanations and the reasons that he changed or I disagree. But all of that is enabled by the transparency that pre-registration provides. It does not replace reasoning in any way. These are pretty radical changes to the way that research is being done. And I'm just wondering, are these practices catching on? Are researchers agreeing, going along and saying, yeah, you know, this is what we should have been doing all along.
接着说明：“这是我们不得不更改的地方。这就是我们必须更改它的原因。这就是我们认为它对你应当多大程度上信任我们的结果所产生的影响。”然后作为读者的你就可以说：“嗯，我很高兴我能看到这一点。我很高兴我能理解他是如何从这里走到那里的，我要么同意他的解释和更改的理由，要么不同意。”但所有这一切都是通过预注册提供的透明度来实现的。它绝不能取代推理。这些对研究开展方式的改变可以说是相当激进的。我只是想知道，这些做法正在流行起来吗？研究人员是否在赞同、顺应，并说：“是的，你知道，这就是我们一直以来应该做的。我全盘接受。”
I'm all in. Yeah. So you opened saying that the critics have firm called this a reproducibility crisis. And I think the term is wrong. And there are many others that have said this as well, that really it's a renaissance. Leif, Joe, and Yuri, the ones who did that initial paper, they have a great paper recently called the Psychology's Renaissance. And it's a very optimistic paper in that it argues, that what these troubling episodes produced was of self-reflection in the psychological community about psychological processes, about how humans and the cultures that they inhabit are themselves influencing sometimes for the negative, but also potentially for the positive, the quality of science and how we produce and understand findings.
是的。所以你在开场时说批评者坚定地称之为“可重复性危机”。我认为这个词是错的。还有许多其他人也这么说过，这实际上是一场文艺复兴。莱夫、乔和乌里（做那篇初步论文的人）最近发表了一篇非常棒的论文，叫做《心理学的文艺复兴》（Psychology's Renaissance）。这是一篇非常乐观的论文，它认为，这些令人不安的插曲在心理学界引发了自我反思，反思内容涵盖心理过程，以及人类及其所处的文化本身如何有时会产生负面影响，但也可能产生正面影响，从而影响科学的质量以及我们产生和理解发现的方式。
So as a consequence of that, there has been a very, broad engagement in the psychological community by bottom-up researchers themselves saying, we need to change this, and so we're going to start to adopt some of these new behaviors, sharing data, pre-registering research, and otherwise, and some top-down, where publishers and editors, funders, and institutions are saying we need to change our reward systems, how it is that we encourage the most credible research that we can. Now, it's 10 years since some of those eliciting events occur that may brought this really to the fore. And it's, you know, culture change takes a long time, but a lot has changed.
因此，作为其结果，心理学界广泛参与其中，底层的研究人员自己说：“我们需要改变这一点，所以我们要开始采用一些这些新的行为，共享数据、预注册研究等。”还有自上而下的推动，出版商、编辑、资助者和机构都在说，我们需要改变我们的奖励系统，改变我们鼓励尽可能最具可信度的研究的方式。现在，距离其中一些引发事件发生已经过去10年了，这些事件可能把这一点真正推到了最前沿。而且，你知道的，文化变革需要很长时间，但很多事情已经改变了。
So just as one example, we operate the open science framework. This is part of what the Center for Open Science does, is this technology where researchers can use this as a collaborative management service, the OSF, where you can share your data and your materials, you can pre-register your designs, etc. The number of users of the OSF, which is open to any discipline, not just psychology, but is more than 300,000 now since it opened in 2012, right? It's been increasing in exponential rates every year. The number of registered studies is in the many, many thousands at this point. Millions of data files have been shared on the OSF.
所以仅举一个例子，我们运营着开放科学框架（Open Science Framework, OSF）。这是开放科学中心所做工作的一部分，是一项让研究人员可以将其作为协作管理服务的技术——OSF，你可以在这里分享你的数据和材料、预注册你的设计等。OSF的用户数量（对任何学科开放，不仅仅是心理学）自2012年开通以来，现在已经超过了30万人，对吧？它每年都在以指数级的速度增长。目前，注册的研究数量已经有成千上万个。数百万个数据文件已经在OSF上分享。
And all of these show this exponential growth, and that is largely driven. by the psychological community. And I think one of the great benefits of psychology confronting this is that really the challenges that are trying to be solved are psychological challenges, right? Challenges with the individual in their behavior, challenges with the system and how individuals react to that system. And so as a consequence of psychology leading the way on a lot of this work, there's a lot of similar sorts of self-reflection and change happening in other disciplines. And so the reproducibility
所有这些都显示出这种指数级增长，而这在很大程度上是由心理学界推动的。我认为心理学正视这一问题带来的巨大好处之一是，真正试图解决的挑战是心理学挑战，对吧？个体及其行为的挑战，系统以及个体对该系统的反应的挑战。因此，随着心理学在这类工作中带头前行，许多其他学科也正在发生许多类似形式的自我反思和变革。因此，可重复性
movement has spanned into biomedicine, into ecology, and evolutionary biology, into pre-clinical disease research, into education research, and business research. So that, I think, is going to be the real, the next 10 years is really the full embrace of these challenges across different scholarly communities. So replicating experiments that have already been conducted isn't seen as a career enhancing move in the sciences. What, if anything, is being done in an attempt to change this, to encourage people to try to reproduce studies? Yeah, replication is an important part of science because it's how we establish the reliability of findings. We rarely do a study to, to make a statement about a historical fact, like, did this thing happen or not?
运动已经扩展到了生物医学、生态学和进化生物学、临床前疾病研究、教育研究和商业研究中。因此，我认为这将是真正的未来10年——在不同的学术社群中全面拥抱这些挑战。因此，在科学界，重复已经进行过的实验并不被视为提升职业生涯的举措。为了改变这一点，鼓励人们尝试重复研究，目前正在采取什么措施（如果有的话）？是的，复制是科学的重要组成部分，因为它是我们确立发现的可靠性的方式。我们很少为了对历史事实做出陈述而进行一项研究，比如，这件事发生了还是没发生？
That isn't usually what a scientific hypothesis or claim would be. Often scientific claims are about if these conditions occur again, then this kind of thing will happen again sometime in the future, right? We're making statements that have general application, make predictions about observations that haven't been made yet. Even if they're about events in the past, we haven't observed them yet, the hypothesis would make an anticipation of what's going to a way. occur. So replication helps with assessing whether those predictions come true when you try to do them
这通常不是科学假设或声明会做的事情。通常，科学声明是关于如果这些条件再次发生，那么未来某个时候就会再次发生这种事情，对吧？我们正在做出具有普遍应用性的陈述，对尚未进行的观察做出预测。即使它们是关于过去事件的，如果我们尚未观察到它们，假设也会对将要发生的方式做出预期。因此，复制有助于评估当你试图在与先前研究类似的语境中再次进行这些预测时，它们是否会成真。
again in similar sorts of contexts as the previous research. But it is entirely valued because of those reward systems that we've been talking about focus on innovation and novelty at the expense of verification credibility. I gain more stature by having a phenomenon with my name on it. The Nosec phenomenon of X, right? Whereas the replication is me trying to assess the credibility of somebody else's claim, usually, could be my own too, but isn't as valued. So there are some things that are changing. One is just a growing appreciation of the role of replication in research. So journals are changing their policies to be more welcoming of replication studies, recognizing that it is important contribution to science. That opens the door. It is becoming easier to do replications
但由于我们一直在讨论的那些奖励系统专注于创新和新颖性，而牺牲了验证和可信度，它并没有得到充分的重视。我的名字如果跟某种现象联系在一起，我会获得更高的声望。比如“诺塞克X现象”，对吧？而复制则是我试图评估别人的（通常也可以是我自己的）主张的可信度，但它没有那么受重视。因此，有些事情正在改变。首先是对复制在研究中所扮演角色的认识不断提高。因此，期刊正在改变它们的政策，更加欢迎复制研究，认识到它是对科学的重要贡献。这打开了大门。复制变得越来越容易，
because researchers are sharing their materials and their data to a greater extent. So now if someone wants to replicate somebody else's findings, they can get a leg up on figuring out how they actually did their research more quickly and easily because of greater sharing. And now there are also new publishing models that lower the barrier to trying replication studies. And one of them is called registered reports. And the idea of registered reports is to really fundamentally change how is it that researchers get that key reward, the publication. In the standard model, I do all of my research, and then I write it up and I submit it
因为研究人员在更大程度上分享他们的材料和数据。因此，现在如果有人想要复制别人的发现，由于更好的分享机制，他们可以更快、更容易地获得关于别人实际是如何进行研究的诀窍。现在也有了新的出版模式，降低了尝试复制研究的门槛。其中之一被称为“注册报告”（Registered Reports）。注册报告的想法是，从根本上改变研究人员如何获得那个关键奖励——发表。在标准模型中，我做完所有的研究，然后将其写下来并在最后提交。
at the end. Here are all my findings. And then the peer reviewers evaluate whether it's credible and whether it should be published. In registered reports, what I submit to the journal is my plan. Here's the question that I'm going to ask. Here's the background material. Here's some initial evidence to say that this is worth studying. And here's my study design and how I plan to analyze my data when I get it.
这是我所有的发现。然后同行评议者评估它是否可信以及是否应该发表。在注册报告中，我提交给期刊的是我的计划。这是我将要提出的问题。这是背景材料。这里有一些初步证据，表明这值得研究。这是我的研究设计以及我打算如何在获得数据后对其进行分析。
And the peer reviewers evaluate, is that an important question? And is the methodology an effective test of that question? And if they agree, then the journal commits to publishing my findings regardless of what happens. and this fundamentally changes what my goal is as the author. Instead of my goal being make the findings as flashy as exciting and as innovative as possible, my goal is ask the most important questions and design the best methods I can to test them, and that will get me the publication. And then the results are the results.
然后同行评议者评估：这是一个重要的问题吗？方法学是否是对该问题的一次有效测试？如果他们同意，那么无论结果如何，期刊都承诺发表我的发现。这从根本上改变了我作为作者的目标。我的目标不再是让发现尽可能华丽、激动人心和具有创新性，而是提出最重要的问题，并设计我能做出的最佳方法来对其进行测试，这就会为我赢得发表的机会。然后结果就是结果。
I just do the research and then I publish whatever happens. And that changes a lot of the things that we've been talking about, right? It eliminates publication bias because the studies are going to get out there, whether they come the way I hoped they would or not. They're all going to be reported because they've been pre-committed in advance. They're going to get reviewed in advance so the rigor can be enhanced compared to reviewing it afterwards where you say, oh, well, you screwed up X, Y, and Z. And I say, great, well, the studies are all done. I can't change that now. But the relevance to replication, which is where you started in asking, is that it also means that I can propose.
我只是进行研究，然后发表无论发生什么结果。这就改变了我们一直在讨论的许多事情，对吧？它消除了发表偏差，因为无论研究结果是否符合我的预期，它们都会公之于众。它们都将被报告，因为它们是事先承诺的。它们将被提前评审，因此与事后评审（你当时说：“哦，好吧，你在X、Y和Z上搞砸了”，而我说：“太好了，但研究都已经做完了，我现在无法改变这一点”）相比，严谨性可以得到提高。但它与复制的相关性（也就是你最初提问时的切入点）在于，这也意味着我可以提议
to do replication studies and get commitments from the journal that they're actually interested in publishing it before I do all of the work to do the replication. And that's a lower-barred entry, right? I can say, well, it's fine. I don't know if they want the replication, but at least I can just write up a proposal for it. And then if they don't want it, then I don't have to do it, save myself some time. So all of those are shifting some rewards for replication, but then also overall how it is people are rewarded in general. Are some of these open science ideas filtering down to training yet? I mean, are undergraduate and graduate students being taught these new methods? Yes, very much so. And that's one of the more exciting elements is that that's really how these sorts of things
进行复制研究，并在我完成复制的所有工作之前，获得期刊对它们实际上有兴趣发表该研究的承诺。这是一个较低的准入门槛，对吧？我可以这样说：“嗯，没关系。我不知道他们是否想要这个复制，但我至少可以为它写一份提案。如果他们不想要，那我就不必做了，从而省了一些时间。”因此，所有这些都在某种程度上改变了对复制的奖励，同时也改变了人们总体上获得奖励的方式。这些开放科学的一些理念是否已经渗透到培训中了？我的意思是，本科生和研究生是否正在被教授这些新方法？是的，非常多。这是最令人兴奋的要素之一，因为这正是这些事情得以维持的方式——
get sustained is where the training that gets integrated into curricula at the graduate and undergraduate levels really starts to embed these new practices. And that's happening in formal cases like methodology instructors at their universities, building them into their coursework. And it's also happening in informal ways where people who are advocates for open science in the community, and it's a very robust, lively community are developing materials and making them available for broad dissemination. So, for example, there is a society called the Society for the Improvement of Psychological Science, SIPs. It's improvingps.com. And the goal of that is to be a very much of a community-based ground swell of ways that we can do better.
将培训整合到研究生和本科水平的课程中，真正开始将这些新实践嵌入其中。这既发生在正式的案例中，例如大学的方法学讲师将它们构建到课程作业中；也发生在非正式的方式中，社区中支持开放科学的人们（这是一个非常强健、活跃的社区）正在开发材料并使其可供广泛传播。例如，有一个名为“心理学科学改进协会”（Society for the Improvement of Psychological Science, SIPs）的社群，网址是improvingps.com。它的目标是成为一个非常注重社区基础的潮流，探索我们可以做得更好的方法。
That might be creating training materials, it might be delivering training, it might be ways to try to change some of these reward systems or anything else. And that community has been fabulous at generating lots and lots of different new training materials or education devices or ways of explaining some of these challenges. There are projects like the Fort Project or the Open Scholarship Knowledge Base that aggregate these materials and then make them more easily available for people to search and discover to bring into their class or to learn themselves. So that's really a big part of the engine of what is helping to sustain this change
这可能是创建培训材料，可能是提供培训，可能是试图改变其中一些奖励系统的方法或其他任何东西。该社区在生成大量不同的新培训材料、教育设备或解释其中一些挑战的方法方面表现得极其出色。有一些项目，如“堡垒项目”（Fort Project）或“开放学术知识库”（Open Scholarship Knowledge Base），它们聚合了这些材料，然后使它们更容易被人们搜索和发现，以便引入他们的课堂或供自己学习。因此，这确实是帮助维持这种变革的重要引擎。
is the community providing training for itself about these issues. So another fascinating thing that you're exploring at the center is faster ways to predict which research results are likely to replicate and which aren't. And I know you've looked at something called prediction markets and also at using artificial intelligence to predict reproducibility. Can you talk about those tools and how they work? Doing a replication is a lot of work. So if we want to know whether a finding is trustworthy or credible, saying, okay, we've got to run it again and get all, another set of participants and spend another year running the study and analyzing it, wow, that's a lot of effort to assess credibility.
社区是否在为自身提供关于这些问题的培训。你在中心正在探索的另一个令人着迷的事情是，寻找更快的方法来预测哪些研究结果可能会被重复，哪些不会。我知道你研究过一种叫作预测市场的东西，还研究过利用人工智能来预测可重复性。你能谈谈这些工具以及它们是如何工作的吗？进行一次重复研究需要做大量的工作。因此，如果我们想知道一个发现是否值得信赖或可信，如果说，好吧，我们必须重新运行它，找到另一组参与者，再花一年时间进行研究和分析，哇，评估可信度需要付出巨大的努力。
And that's essential and important and will continue to be part of the process for as long as we can envision what science will be. But it would be useful to have other indicators that gave us a more rapid assessment of the credibility of finding. So peer review is supposed to provide that, but that still is a lot of effort, right? the reader has to read it all and decide do they think it's a credible finding or not. Wouldn't it be awesome if we could have machines read the papers and decide whether those findings were credible or not? Yeah, that'd be great. Then it would be a lot less work. It'd be a lot
这非常重要，并且将继续作为这个过程的一部分，只要我们能够设想科学将会是什么样。但如果有其他指标能让我们更快地评估研究发现的可信度，那就很有用了。因此同行评审应该提供这一点，但这仍然需要付出很多努力，对吧？读者必须全部阅读它，并决定他们认为这是一个可信的发现还是不信。如果我们能让机器阅读论文并决定这些发现是否可信，那该有多棒？是的，那太好了。这样工作量就会少得多。速度会快得多
faster. But of course, can machines actually do that? I don't know. So that is sort of the goal of this program that we are part of. And there's hundreds of collaborators involved in this program. It's called score. The idea is to see if it's possible to create algorithms, artificial intelligence, that will score papers and particular findings or claims from papers on their credibility. And if that works, then it provides an initial heuristic that readers, like you or me, can make about papers. So if I pass my own paper through the machine to say what's the scores on it, I might learn something about where the evidence, at least from the machine's perspective, is stronger or weaker. And then that might help guide me for saying,
。但当然，机器真的能做到这一点吗？我不知道。所以这可以说是我们参与这个项目的目标。这个项目有数百名合作者参与。它叫作score。其理念是看是否有可能创建算法和人工智能，来对论文以及论文中的特定发现或主张的可信度进行评分。如果这行得通，那么它将为像你或我这样的读者提供一个初步的启发式判断。因此，如果我把自己的论文通过机器来了解其得分，我可能会了解到证据在哪些方面（至少从机器的角度来看）更强或更弱。然后这可能会指导我
oh, I need to bolster that with some additional citation evidence or other evidence that already exists. I might need to do another study there, or I might need to sort of look and at least look closer. Right, you as a reviewer might do the same. Or as an editor might say, oh, it would be really useful to make sure we have an expert on that topic because the machines gave an initial indication of this is an area of high uncertainty. So that's the goal is to create some tools like that to help facilitate and direct resources for the deeper dives into the evidence credibility. So why do we think we can accomplish that? Well, there's actually some evidence that it might work. So the first bit of evidence is that we in collaboration with a number of others, particularly
，哦，我需要用一些额外的引文证据或已经存在的其他证据来支撑它。我可能需要在那里做另一项研究，或者我可能需要仔细看看，至少更仔细地看看。没错，作为审稿人，你可能也会这样做。或者作为编辑，你可能会说，哦，确保我们有该领域的专家真的很有用，因为机器给出了初步迹象，表明这是一个高度不确定性的领域。所以这就是目标，即创建一些这样的工具，来帮助促进和指导资源，以便对证据的可信度进行更深入的探究。那么为什么我们认为我们能够实现这一目标呢？嗯，实际上有一些证据表明它可能会管用。因此，第一点证据是，我们与许多其他人合作，特别是
a great group of economists, have run prediction markets where people bet on whether findings would replicate or not. It gave them money and said, you can buy shares. You know, buy a yes share. If it succeeds in replication, you get paid. If it fails, you lose that money. You buy no shares. Then you're betting against it, et cetera.
一个优秀的经济学家团队，曾经营过预测市场，人们可以在其中押注发现是否会重复。它给他们钱并说，你可以买股票。你知道的，买一张“是”的股票。如果重复成功，你会得到报酬。如果失败了，你就会失去这笔钱。你买“否”的股票。然后你就在对冲它，等等。
And those markets were quite successful at anticipating replication outcomes when done in these systematic studies, suggesting that people have information that can anticipate whether findings are likely to replicate or not. And similar findings that observe with surveys and other kinds of elicitation techniques to see assess credibility. And then a few different teams have tried with machines, is train machines on reading, papers, give them a training set, and then give them outcomes of whether those successfully replicated or not, and then test them with papers that have replications associated with them that the machines had never seen before. And they performed similarly to the humans in predicting which papers were likely to produce
当在这些系统性研究中进行时，这些市场在预测重复结果方面相当成功，这表明人们拥有可以预测发现是否可能重复的信息。在通过调查和其他类型的启发技术来评估可信度时，也观察到了类似的发现。然后，几个不同的团队尝试用机器来做这件事，让机器训练阅读论文，给它们一个训练集，然后给它们这些论文是否成功重复的结果，接着用机器从未见过的、带有相关重复研究的论文来测试它们。它们的表现与人类类似，能够预测哪些论文可能会产生
replicable findings and which were likely to fail to replicate. So those initial studies were sort of the basis of doing this project at some. scale, the score project, which is doing this across the social behavioral sciences and involving thousands of papers and hundreds of replication studies and prediction markets and elicitations of confidence and multiple different artificial intelligence groups, all trying to see if we can really create robust automated prediction of credibility. And if it works, then it has lots of potential applications and lots of potential risks of overuse and inappropriate use. So it'll be a very interesting challenge to navigate of how one would use these appropriately, responsibly,
可复制的发现，哪些可能会复制失败。因此，这些初步研究可以说是该项目在一定规模上开展的基础，即score项目，该项目在社会行为科学领域开展，涉及数千篇论文、数百项重复研究、预测市场、信心启发以及多个不同的人工智能团队，所有这些都在试图弄清楚我们是否真的能够创建稳健的、自动化的可信度预测。如果它管用，那么它将有许多潜在的应用以及滥用和不当使用的潜在风险。因此，如何适当地、负责任地
and effectively to help address research credibility and improve it. Last question for our listeners who, as I mentioned earlier, are just people who are interested in the science of psychology, not necessarily scientists or researchers themselves. How can they think about the issues that we've discussed today? Is there some way for them to know whether a paper has gone through the process of open data, open science, registration? How are you getting the word out there to more of a lay audience, particularly people who just get a lot of their science by reading more popular publications, for example, or listening to other podcasts? Yeah, no, it's a big challenge is how do we create effective signals of credibility for different degrees of engagement with the research finding. I am a practicing scientist and I only read a very, very tiny portion of the research literature, right?
且有效地使用这些工具来帮助解决研究可信度问题并加以改进，将是一个非常有趣的挑战。给我们的听众的最后一个问题，正如我刚才提到的，他们只是对心理学科学感兴趣的人，不一定是科学家或研究人员本身。他们如何看待我们今天讨论的问题？有没有什么方法让他们知道一篇论文是否经历了开放数据、开放科学、注册的过程？你是如何向更多非专业听众宣传这一点的，特别是那些通过阅读更多大众出版物或听其他播客来获取大部分科学知识的人？是的，这确实是一个巨大的挑战，我们如何针对对研究发现的不同程度的参与，建立有效的可信度信号？我是一名从业科学家，我只阅读了极小一部分的研究文献，对吧？
So like an everyday person, most of what I know of science, I also get through the same mechanisms, right? Reading in the newspaper or otherwise. I can't read all of those papers. There's millions of papers. So that it is true not just for the layperson, it's true for every person that we need more effective dissemination of the credibility, the confidence that we should have in different findings. Part of that is education about how science actually works, right, which is initial findings are always uncertain. When that first study that comes out and says, coffee is terrible for you, you know that next year of study is going to come out and say coffee is the best thing. you could ever drink. Don't stop drinking coffee. And then on and on and on, right? Because it's
所以就像一个普通人一样，我对科学的大部分了解也是通过相同的机制获得的，对吧？在报纸上阅读或其他方式。我无法阅读所有这些论文。有数百万篇论文。因此，这不仅适用于外行人，对于每个人来说都是如此，我们需要更有效地传播可信度，传播我们对不同发现应该具有的信心。其中一部分是关于科学实际运作方式的教育，对吧，也就是最初的发现总是具有不确定性的。当第一项研究出来说咖啡对你非常糟糕时，你知道明年的研究就会出来说咖啡是你能喝到的最好的东西。不要停止喝咖啡。然后没完没了，对吧？因为
really hard to figure it out. You can't randomly assign people. You're going to drink coffee now is the only thing you're going to drink for the rest of your life. And you're going to drink, not coffee, for the rest of your life. And then we'll see who lives longer. And you're just, the kinds of studies to actually unpack these phenomena with confidence aren't going to be done. And so the evidence accumulation for a lot of the things that we read about is slow and uncertain and subject to change, and that's fine. In fact, it's ordinary. And so the one caution, I think, that just any of us should have is not expecting more from science than it can deliver in the short term. Science works on long time scales, and the confidence that we have is accumulation over time and building of evidence
弄清楚这一点真的很难。你不能随机指派人们。你从现在开始只能喝咖啡，这是你余生唯一能喝的东西。而你余生都不能喝咖啡。然后我们看看谁活得更长。而且，真正充满信心地剖析这些现象的研究是不会完成的。因此，我们阅读的许多事情的证据积累是缓慢的、不确定的、易变的，这没问题。事实上，这是很平常的。因此，我认为我们任何人都应该保持的一个警惕是，不要对科学抱有过高的期望，不要指望它能在短期内提供超出其能力的东西。科学是在漫长的时间尺度上运作的，我们所拥有的信心是随着时间的推移而积累和证据的构建
And I shouldn't say over time necessarily, it can be done very quickly with lots and lots of resource investment, right? COVID vaccines is a perfect example of that. The vaccines themselves, the amount of evidence gathered in a short period of time is astonishing. Of course, it's billions of dollars got put into making sure that we got that evidence. He got it credibly very quickly. and those particular vaccines are built on 30, 40 years of accumulated research on the basic processes of how it is that we could develop those more quickly. So it feels like it happened all the sudden,
并且我不应该说一定随着时间推移，如果投入大量资源，它也可以很快完成，对吧？新冠疫苗就是一个完美的例子。疫苗本身，在短时间内收集到的证据数量是惊人的。当然，投入了数十亿美元来确保我们获得这些证据。它非常迅速地以可信的方式得到了证据，而这些特定的疫苗是建立在对我们如何能够更快地开发这些疫苗的基本过程的30、40年积累的研究基础之上的。所以感觉这一切发生得很突然
but it actually happened over many, many, many years of accumulating process and insight and evidence. So I got a little bit off track there, but the basic point, like, who can't think about COVID these days, right? Right, right. But the basic point is that just is caution, is science is slow, and so take evidence as tentative. And the more signals that you have about transparency, the better. And that doesn't mean that it's right. It does mean that it's possible that you can self-correct or obtain accurate assessments
，但它实际上是经过多年、多年、多年的积累过程、洞察力和证据才发生的。所以我有点偏离正题了，但基本的观点是，这几天谁能不考虑新冠肺炎呢，对吧？对，对。但基本的观点只是保持警惕，科学是缓慢的，所以把证据视为暂时的。你关于透明度的信号越多越好。这并不意味着它是正确的。这确实意味着你有可能更容易地进行自我修正或获得准确的信心评估
of confidence more easily. Well, this has been really interesting. I appreciate you're talking to us today, Dr. Nose. and I learned a lot about the renaissance that we're experiencing right now in scientific research. Thank you. Good. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at speakingof psychology.org
。嗯，这真的很有趣。诺斯博士，我很感激你今天跟我们谈话，我学到了很多关于我们在科学研究中正在经历的文艺复兴的知识。谢谢。好的。谢谢你邀请我。你可以在speakingof psychology.org
or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在Apple、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》之前的节目。请给我们留个评论。如果你对未来的播客有什么评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是speaking of psychology at APA.org。那就是speaking of psychology，连在一起，在APA.org。Speaking of Psychology由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Kondyin。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。